and that is all the mistakes which were
made we're made team face of Russian
sweat what Russia is still alive and
surely it's a great country powerful
country with enormous strong sense of
its of its destiny and and it would be
good for Poland to remember is that
these every indeed the future of Ukraine
the last point if I have still time do I
have or not just feel a few questions
that I told you that I have I wanted
just to share with you sis fused salts
which as I said very has it and I'm very
uncomfortable talking about it because
I'm not sure of myself at all but
nevertheless about the church and
churches somehow I probably will not be
so concerned about that if we didn't
have 19th century that is 19th century
killed civic society destroy civic
society destroys the citizens of Poland
Ukraine lithuania all of that was
destroyed finish on a place of the
citizens came the subject and with that
all the institution also went through
big changes I think that feeling that
that in church relations or church-state
relations opposition of churches inside
of the Commonwealth something very
peculiar happened which I don't think is
quite well notice and that is I would
call it domestication of the churches
that is process which we call separation
of state and church or subject
education of church to the state powers
I was done in mostly in Europe in
different places of Europe in different
way but mostly through the actions of
the representatives of state government
it seems to me that the very similar
subjugation control of state of churches
we're done on territories of
Commonwealth by society by forces of
society by by basically by those who
were part of the churches before that on
that territories kind of putting on
place hierarchies or putting in place
churches wassa was probably similar to
the process which was happening only in
one country and that was united states
in this 17th 18th century especially
18th century that is what probably I'm
just mentioning that as a possibility
also to to look to in the studies of our
past which however however well already
known still can give us additional
questions to answer and as always we do
ask questions for the purpose of today
and for the purpose of tomorrow thank
you very much
as the question is do I steal is five
minutes you see where to start but this
I enter this with trepidation because
some of you may have looked at the
Poland and Ukraine volume that the ship
sank o society has out a conference from
1981 and you can read in that conference
papers by Kaminski in Sisson dealing
with Polish Ukrainian relations 16th to
18th centuries and a bit later we
reassemble doing that I might add that
volume was available on a book bundle
list with a low number of Polish
Ukrainian books for our Institute their
flyers on a great deal there for those
of you who want to catch up with that
but what is true is that many of these
issues which we discussed it began
discussing then and professor Kaminski
frequently came up to Harvard in those
days and the Harvard Ukrainian Institute
was I think a center for this kind of
discussion not so much with scholars
from the US but more with scholars from
Poland who frequently came in those days
and I think there was much creative done
just by those mutual discussions in that
period much as I think that's important